wir haben viel über antisemitische und
anti israelische demonstrationen auf
deutschlands straßen berichten müssen in
letzter zeit und das obwohl israel seit
wochen von einer neuen terrorwelle
überzogen wird seit ende märz wurden bei
mehreren anschlägen auf israelis 14
menschen getötet erst gestern
ausgerechnet am israelischen
unabhängigkeitstag kam erneut drei
menschen bei einem attentat ums leben
und trotz dieser terrorwelle anti israel
demos in deutschland statt
solidaritätskundgebungen das muss und
das soll sich auch ändern das hat
berlins bürgermeisterin heute gegenüber
bild versprochen
demos wie diese am 24 april in berlin
gibt es immer wieder offener judenhass
findet dort statt hass auf israel mitten
auf deutschen straßen auch journalisten
werden dort regelmäßig attackiert
zuletzt bild reporter peter wilke
doch er ist nicht der einzige auch bild
-chef reporterin antonia amin selbst
jüdin und deutsch israelin wurde vor
einem jahr opfer dieses menschenhass es
ebenfalls mitten in berlin mitten in
neukölln
antonia jamin arbeitet zu diesem
zeitpunkt für das öffentlich rechtliche
israelische fernsehen ein böller wurde
gezielt auf sie geschossen
heute berichtet antonia aus berlin vom
wittenbergplatz wo der 74 jahrestag der
gründung israels gefeiert wird auch
diese veranstaltung musste heute von 150
polizisten geschützt werden hier trifft
sie die regierende bürgermeisterin von
berlin franziska giffey will wissen wann
dieser offene judenhass in berlin auf
hört ganz klar
antisemitische israelfeindliche
äußerungen auf demonstrationen werden
wir nicht zulassen am 15 mai werden wir
es sehen da findet der sogenannte nakba
tag statt an dem viele araber ihren hass
auf israel und die juden freien lauf
lassen anlass die teilung palästinas in
einem arabischen und einen israelischen
teil bild reporterin antonia jamin wird
die regierende bürgermeisterin an ihren
worten messen wie er bei bild werden
auch bei den nächsten palästinensischen
demonstrationen mit dabei sein und
überprüfen ob die bürgermeisterin ihr
versprechen hält